- [Instructor] So they are telling us that
r fifths is equal to eight tenths
and we need to figure out
what is r going to be equal to
and they help us out with this number line
where they've put eight
tenths on the number line.
That makes sense because
to go from zero to one,
they've split it into
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, ten equal jumps
and at this point, we have
gone eight of those ten
equal jumps between zero and
one so that is eight tenths
and they've also labeled one fifth for us
and one way to think about it is
if we look at these bold lines,
zero,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
if you just look at the purple,
we have five equal jumps.
So each of those jumps are a fifth
and so it makes sense that our first jump
right over here gets us to one fifth
and you can see that
that is equivalent to two of the tenths.
I'll just write that up here
so we can see that equivalence.
One fifth is equal to two tenths
but how many fifths is
equal to eight tenths?
Pause this video and try to figure it out.
All right, well this is one fifth.
If we do one more jump of a
fifth, that would be two fifths.
Then if we go another fifth,
that will get us to three fifths
and then if we go another fifth,
that will get us to four fifths
which we see is exactly
equivalent to eight tenths
and that makes sense
because we also saw that
every fifth is equivalent to two tenths.
So four fifths is going to be equivalent
to eight of those tenths.
We see that very clearly right over here
and so r is equal to four.
Four fifths is equal to eight tenths.
So r is equal to four.
Let's do another example.
What fraction is equivalent to point A?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, so let's figure
out where point A is.
So to go from zero to one,
we have one, two, three,
four, five, six equal jumps.
So each of these jumps are a sixth.
So going from zero, one jump
will get us to one sixth,
then two sixths, then three sixths,
then four sixths, then five sixths
and so can we see four
sixths in the choices?
No I do not see four sixths.
So we have to find an equivalent
fraction to four sixths.
So we could go choice by choice.
The first choice has five sixths.
Well we very clearly see that five sixths
would be here on the number line
which is clearly a different
place than four sixths.
So we could rule out this first choice
but what about these other ones?
Let's see, let's see
how we can think about.
Four fifths versus four sixths.
Could those be equivalent?
If I have four out of five
versus four out of six,
that's not feeling too good
so I'm gonna put like a
curly line through it.
That's not feeling right,
that if I could have
four out of five equal jumps
or five equal sections,
that that would be the same
as four out of six equal sections.
If I divided it into six equal sections,
each of those sections are
going to be a little bit
smaller than if I divided
into five equal sections.
So if I have four of each,
they're going to be a different value.
Actually when I talk it out like that,
I feel even more confident
that I could rule this one out.
Now what about six fourths?
Well one way to think about it
is four fourths would be equal to one.
So six fourths is going to be beyond one.
So it's definitely not
going to be where A is,
so I could rule that one out
and we could say oh, well
maybe it's just going to be D
but let's make sure that this makes sense.
Two thirds, what does
two thirds look like?
Well let me try to divide
this part of the number line
from zero to one into thirds,
into three equal sections.
So I have zero there
and then that could be one third,
two thirds and then three thirds.
That looks like three equal sections.
So this is one third,
this is two thirds, I'm
making another jump of a third
and then when I get to one,
of course that is three thirds
or we could have said six sixths
and so point A,
which is right over here
I'm writing over it,
that is indeed equal to two thirds.
You can see each jump of a
third is equal to two sixths.
So it makes sense that four
sixths is equal to two thirds
or that two thirds is equal to four sixths
so I like this one.